So we have a really dicey situation that is
sort of the coming together of Donald Trump's
voter suppression tactics and demeaning a
vote by mail and absentee ballots.
Donald Trump's nomination of Amy CONI Barrett
to the Supreme Court, which could directly
impact what ultimately happens with many absentee
ballots, which could ultimately impact the
results of this election, particularly if
it is close.
We know that there are some Democratic wins
for both the presidency and the Senate, which
could actually hinge on hinge on absentee
ballots.
And we already have a snafu.
We could call it per the intercept.
More than 100000 absentee ballot requests
have already been invalidated in multiple
Iowa counties.
In late August, judges ordered two Iowa counties
to invalidate at least 64000 ballot requests,
siding with Donald Trump.
The Trump campaign brought a legal challenge.
The Republican Party brought this legal challenge.
They've been filing these lawsuits all over
the country.
We told you they were ready with an army of
lawyers.
They are already deploying them.
About 50000 voters in one county, 14000 voters
in another county.
We'll be informed that their requests for
an absentee ballot won't count.
And if you still want to vote by mail, you
have to send a new form.
So you have here 64000 people, plus ninety
two thousand in a separate case in Johnson
County, which is where University of Iowa
is expecting a more Abidin leaning electorate
in that county.
This is like a total of about 150000 ballots
now that we are talking about.
They set requests for an absentee ballot.
Those have now been invalidated.
Thanks to this lawsuit.
And many of those people may not know it.
They may be sitting there waiting for their
absentee ballot to arrive, which may never
arrive unless they submit a new request.
Then early last week, a fourth judge sided
with the Trump campaign and the Republican
Party, upholding a recent law making absentee
voting harder.
In Iowa, Republicans push the law in Iowa
over the summer.
It slows down the process for getting through
and sending out the absentee ballots.
It makes it more difficult to get people their
ballots on time.
What are Democratic Party officials doing?
They're scrambling.
They're, you know, always half a step to two
steps behind.
They need to now try to contact people who
believe they have an absentee ballot coming
to them, but actually don't.
And they need to figure out how do we communicate
with these people?
How do we get everybody to request a new absentee
ballot?
Very expensive, not impossible, but very expensive.
So is there any good news here?
OK, if I need to find some good news.
The good news is in most electoral map scenarios,
Iowa is not likely to be the deciding state.
It's unlikely that to Biden, getting to 270
electoral votes will hinge on the results
in Iowa.
The bad news is they're going to pull this
and they're already polling this in many different
states.
So we have to understand the timelines and
we have to understand the deadlines.
Monday, two days ago, was the deadline to
register in many states.
I mean, I'll give you the list, even though
the deadline has.
Vast areas.
Arizona, Arkansas, Florida, Georgia, Hawaii,
Indiana, Kentucky, Louisiana, Mississippi,
Ohio, South Carolina, Tennessee and Texas.
Did you register?
Because if you didn't.
It's too late.
OK.
If you're unsure if you're registered, Google
check voter registration, your state and you
will figure out how to confirm your status.
Delaware is coming up on October 10th.
You have until October 10th to register in
Delaware.
Idaho is October 9th.
Illinois was yesterday.
Maryland is next Monday.
I believe it is.
Missouri is today.
You have until today to register in Missouri.
New Mexico is yesterday.
New York is Friday.
These dates are coming.
The election is happening now.
There is no more time to wait.
Vote Dawg has all of the information about
how to register.
How to get an absentee ballot.
How, when and where to vote early.
Everything you need.
We had early voting start this week in California,
Iowa, Maine, Nebraska, South Carolina.
If you're in those states, you can start to
vote now.
Early voting in Indiana and Ohio started yesterday.
Arizona starts today and Georgia starts Monday.
Kentucky and Texas Tuesday.
A bunch more next Wednesday.
The election is now, my friends, and this
is not the time to keep waiting for something.
It is time to act.
Right now, they are going to pull every dirty
trick that they can.
They have lawyers ready to go.
They will try to challenge absentee ballots.
They will try to stop the counting of absentee
ballots.
A new poll, which I'll talk about tomorrow,
has Donald Trump down.
Hope you're sitting 21 points.
It's just one poll, but the numbers are getting
very ugly for Trump.
And the uglier they get, the more all caps
tweets we can expect to see from him on Twitter
and the more they are going to try to use
lawyers and other subterfuge to steal this
election.
There is no more need to wait to remove the
insanity.
The election is now.
Yes, we need automatic voter registration.
There's this this entire paradigm of registering
to vote and deadlines.
Disaster.
OK, we need to fix it.
We need to fix so many problems.
But we have four weeks minus a day.
Right, 27 days to go.
We have to vote right now.
We will keep pushing this, make sure for the
latest updates on voting and how it's going.
That you're following us on Instagram at David
Pakman show.
And while you're there, follow me on Instagram
at Davidge.